like it's kind of surreal being here and
watching it happen live cuz I've seen it
online like so many times and I wanted
to come for like months for the perfect
thing to be Japanese alright so we just
got to Osaka we're on our way now to go
try a rarest take in the world oh I'm so
high like I've seen it online so many
times I watch this video like a million
times
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't think I ever have options on the
line
[Music]
[Music]
he's out there so we're having a good
time so far
this is like a four-course meal every
militant fire I'm watching abroad James
no why do you we tried
[Music]
okay yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you see right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no the hikers room like the hive is very
real like I would be on the Wagyu steak
every day we it goes positive but it's
not it's not it's barely in the US
barely in Japan that's rude but tell one
thing my favorite part was actually the
blobster really I'm gonna say my
favorite part was definitely to both of
the stage mani
I love Wagyu steak was really know
beside the fact that you never try
lobster it was good but the steak was
like yeah now it's time to take a nap so
we just finished up trying our olive
Wagyu and it was fine right y'all good
yeah so what do you think is it worth it
like just a little tonight good pretty
worth it
this is olive Wagyu steak the rare steak
in the world and it was then also the
sirloin was good too like the laps was
great like a whole layout yeah that
pretty much sums it up that's very good
salmon so yeah this would really go
something that you don't only have to
come to Japan for but it's mainly in
Japan this is where it originated this
is a good experience oh yeah
is that like a thumbs up yeah are we
[Music]